hello and welcome to Hillsdale College
I'm David Whalen here with dr. Larry
Arne president of Hillsdale college
president now for 20 years were here to
discuss the meaning and the import of
the 4th of July and some of the
principles of the founding that may have
particular relevance for our own times
as everyone knows these are times of
some strife and turmoil about matters of
race matters of justice and I think the
Declaration and the Constitution and
some of the thoughts of the founders and
later American thinkers have much light
to shed on those very subjects so
welcome and dr. Arne thank you for
joining us so this is a good time to
consider founding principles but what
about the larger question why would
something so old as the Declaration or
why would something so distant as the
founding of the country
have any bearing or relation to current
events well first of all the answer is
contained in the word principle itself
principle means two things it means
first and defining quality and Magritte
equivalent is our K we get archaeology
from that or architecture and why would
those two things go together when I
would first and defining principle or
defining idea go together well if it if
it's a thing it has to have some meaning
and the principle of a thing is both the
original meaning and the meaning and so
come to find out and and if you later
change the principle then you've got a
new thing it's not the same thing
anymore I like to say about all these
colleges that rewrite their mission
statements every 10 years I see remember
here we don't have any authority to do
that nobody gave us that job right and
if we did I think when you rewrite your
mission statement you've started
something new right and that would only
be done because of some dissatisfaction
from the original which just can be true
right there can be reason for that
in our particular founding at Hillsdale
College the principle of the nation's
they did in the Declaration of
Independence and the principal of the
college standing stated in its founding
articles are the same principles that's
what brought me here by the way I didn't
I thought it'd be the dumbest thing in
the world to try to run a college and
sometimes I still think so but but I
thought okay that's beautiful can't we
do it in light of that can't we run our
college can't we find you know colleges
are incredibly fractious places today
right and that's bad because colleges
need to be places of friendship to do
their work they have to because you have
to speculate you have to think you have
to correct yourself and others and it's
not like anybody comes to a college to
represent something they are human
beings engaging in the Humane studies to
find out the right way to live and think
so the point is this principle that our
college is founded on is like the one
the country is founded on and I you know
the great the greatest prophet and
apostle of the Declaration penance turns
out to be Abraham Lincoln who's one of
the greatest men who ever lived
they are defacing statues of Lincoln
right now for shame
right but here's something he said once
he's describing what it is what does it
mean the Deaf rights do depends he says
they meant to set up a standard Maxim
for free society which should be
familiar to all revered by all
constantly look to constantly laboured
for and here's a key point
and even though never perfectly attained
constantly approximated and thereby
giving constantly spreading and
deepening its influence and augmenting
the happiness and value of the life of
all people of all colors everywhere and
you see if a principle is perfect and
the difference is a sort of a grand
tautology by the way to say all men are
created equal means all men me
men and women all human beings are human
beings right well that's perfect and and
then on the other hand human life is
imperfect and so you you have to
remember that it's something to be
sought and the closer one gets to it the
better one is but you'll never get
closer to it by abandoning it you
mentioned that friendship is one of the
principles of a college or should be
must be if any real learning is to occur
there but what does friendship in a
polity look like what is friendship in a
country look like well civic friendship
right so you're Finn your friends are
people who serve the same objects is you
know human to human beings are identical
no human beings are even identical in
the principles they serve but broadly
speaking somebody who believes that I
should eat you and somebody who believes
that you should not they're never going
to be friends they can't agree and so so
this friendship you know it's you know I
I think that America despite its many
flaws is a magical place I was talking
to some I went down to a conference in
Guatemala and I great little University
of they're called Francisco American
University and there was a bunch of kids
from that University staffing the
conference and so one night I gathered
up a bunch of them and took him to
dinner
and we talked for five hours eventually
grown-ups you know who'd been sitting
with each other because they're so
important they saw we were where the fun
was and they came and joined us right
and what did we talk about many of had
been to America all I wanted to go and
and the first thing I asked this very
bright young woman I said what's the
thing about America she said it works so
well and I said what does that mean and
she said people relate to each other
by and large they trust each other he
they trade they buy the cell they serve
and I said not like that here and she
said not as much hmm
you see well I think it doesn't matter
in principle how you're born you you're
a human being and the assumption is
you're a fellow citizen also aiming for
the right principles of you know live
and let live and be free and help each
other mm-hmm well to go back to college
college is much more radical example of
such a thing because weird College
itself it means partnership right and
that means that we've got to get to the
bottom of this and that doesn't mean
we've got to find out our own
perspective it doesn't mean we have to
average the many perspectives which is
the rage and the academic world today it
means let us do what what happens in
Socrates conversations Plato's dialogues
and also Aristotle treatises let's start
with what we know and or think we know
and let's compare and let's work and
let's go upwards in our understanding
and that's the way a college works and
and so it seems to me that it was
providential at least as regarded me in
my career for sure that the people who
founded this college were classically
educated Christian Patriots and that
seems to me this very day to be a good
thing to be right let me play devil's
advocate for just a second half a second
maybe isn't the kind of learning even
the friendship perhaps that you describe
as typical or proper to a college isn't
that kind of a luxury in troubled times
and aren't these troubled times and
shouldn't we all be possessed of an
urgency to to do something well first of
all so like it's it's a luxury it's the
luxury in any time it's a privilege to
get to do that and people think today
what they think is I think left and you
think right and you know I think black
and you think white whatever I think and
so we're going to mix them all up and
the
truth will emerge from some average or
something of them but liberal education
is different than that
liberal education first of all it grows
across the ages hmm you looking for
diversity right you know read the Greeks
and the Persians you know and and and so
first of all you confront the whole
sweep of it and then second you focus on
the books that are particularly that are
serious books and there's a way to tell
I mean there's controversy about it but
if anybody doubts that Shakespeare was a
good play right it means they have not
read him with attention mm-hmm and if
anybody doubts that Plato you know
modern philosophers have said that the
history of philosophy is a footnote to
Plato's dialogues because what do they
do they're all the same and different
you know wide variations but they all do
this they all start with a conversation
and somebody says something other than
the question of the truth of that
something so the point is it gives you a
golden opportunity to step back from the
pressures of the day right so the point
is you you what college is for is to
find the truth even outside the
circumstances that prevail today and
that's a very that's a luxury that's a
wonderful thing to get to do and it does
turn out to inform your life in
wonderful ways it you know like right
now there's an emergency is it you need
you know you'd have to know some history
to know if it is or not is it the worst
you'd have to know about the others
study in the past would be a really
great way to find that out in fact the
only way I'm thinking to of that remark
of CS Lewis during World War two when
when he spoke about the importance of
learning even in times maybe especially
in times of crisis he he spoke about all
of life being lived in a crisis and and
that man naturally inclined toward the
highest kind of learning which he's
capable it's
permanent feature of the human soul to
desire profound understanding and in
part because life and circumstances are
so perplexing and apparently changeable
but I think a lot of people are vaguely
troubled that somehow things have
changed to the point where those grand
old patriotic principles are kind of
dusty and again irrelevant Hillsdale
College teaches a lot about those
principles with the specific notion that
those are a practical and they're
theoretical they're high but they also
have a bearing on the proper conduct of
life now yeah so here's Calvin Coolidge
this is on the hundred and fiftieth
anniversary of the Declaration of
Independence
it is often asserted that the world has
made a great deal of progress in 1776
there were new thoughts and new
experiences which have given us a great
advance over the people of that day but
that reasoning cannot be applied to this
great Charter the Declaration of
Independence if all men are created
equal that is final if they are endowed
with their inalienable rights that is
final if governments derive their just
powers from the consent of the governed
that is final no advance no progress can
be made beyond these propositions you
see it's a what Lincoln calls a standard
maximum for a free society can never be
perfectly attained you know by the way
was not in the time of the founder you
know some of them were slaveholders
right people call them hypocrites for
the most part they were not that they
condemned slavery including their own
practice of it and and they can be
forgiven for that or not but the
principle that they thought condemned it
is the only one that will actually work
and so you know again if you could stand
outside the pressure of these events
which you knows to a considerable extent
are pushed forward is an agitation to
sweep away everything all history that's
why these statues are coming down
and you know you need to read the novel
1984 and see where that could go
because the protagonists job in 1984 and
there are thousands or millions of
people employed in this job is that he
sits all day and he receives orders from
the primary from the party about the
meaning and character of this historical
factor this historical person and then
he found every written reference to that
and altered it as the party class and
that gave them perfect control over
history and that meant that they were
the Lords of history mm-hmm right well
you can't do that the better the right
attitude is stated by Aristotle and
echoed by Thomas Aquinas this alone is
denied even to God to make what has been
not to have been so given the timeliness
of some of these ideas and principles
the college is not a think-tank the
college does not propose policy
prescriptions or specific measures to
ameliorate this or that problem social
ill are there however this may be too
big a question but are there guidelines
or Prudential governing ideas that would
help people think about contemporary
affairs in light of principles of
equality the universal Equality of all
human beings the importance and and
meaning of something like property the
the importance and meaning of work
sometimes those general ideas and
principles sound awfully ethereal and
abstract and the matters of the day seem
desperately and irreducibly concrete are
there some general ideas about how they
can link those well the government the
United States is like like according to
Aristotle the government the cotton
nature the essence of everything
is composed of some parts and add the
two most important parts for interesting
America is there's a final cause let us
say what's it after what is it love what
does it want
that's indecorous independence there's a
formal cause that is to say how does it
work what does it look like how does it
operate there's an outline of that in
the middle of the Declaration of
Independence people forget that when
they talk about the bad stuff the king
did that justified the revolution they
mentioned separation of powers and
consent of the governed and
representation and property now just
think you know because these these ideas
are the products of you know at least
2000 years of thinking what's property
rights about well in one way we're just
like any animal we got to eat we got to
sleep we got a drink if we don't do
those things regularly we will die
and so having this gift of Reason which
gives us foresight we understand that it
be risky to just make enough for
yourself for the given day and so you
store some up right and that's your
property Lincoln says property is the
fruit of Labor mmm labor is superior to
capital but capital is the fruit of
Labor now how did Lincoln condemn
slavery the answer is in a thousand ways
but here's one of my favorites and it's
paraphrase God made every man with one
head one mouth and two hands the
implication being that the head should
guide the hands in the feeding of the
mouth in another place Stephen Douglas
said in one of the lincoln-douglas
debates I do this very town
Lincoln's friend Fred Douglas a hero
around here was driven through this town
and a carriage driven by a white man you
want to see that kind of thing and you
know people didn't a lot a lot of people
Lincoln replies he says and see Lincoln
you should read those debates Lincoln is
the one who can become sublime
and he says maybe it's a black woman who
uses woman might not be your equal you
think
but in her right to eat the bread that
she earns with the sweat of her own face
she is the equal of every being every
human being right
well that's property and you know if we
were cast out into the wilderness after
we've got our daily bread
we'd immediately start thinking about
tomorrow and we try to store up
something for that right how does that
necessity connect to or relate to to the
matter of Education to the matter of a
good human life it's not just meeting a
kind of minimum need is it you know that
is the the very idea of property says
something important about human nature
other than it's an animal nature that
needs sustenance yeah so education is
both the way we raise our young it comes
from a Latin phrase it means to lead
forth
whichever way fourth is and it also is
an activity good for its own sake and
you know it requires property because
the people who are engaged in it are not
busy making a living this is the young
ones right and they and so there has to
be property stored up in this society
and you know every family needs it
because it takes effort and trouble to
raise your children you need some
surplus in order to be able to do that
right and and so the those things are
just written in the ordinary common
nature of things and if you if you go
thinking about it just from the point of
view of systems of economics capitalism
versus socialism right you might miss a
point and the point is one aspect of
living a fully human life is to solve
the problems that the complex of
problems that are constituted by
attempting to live well to raise your
children right to have your family right
to make a living
to learn so that you can live a richer
life of the mind and also on practical
affairs and that and that that effort
you know the promise of America never
fully realized the promise of America is
that each should have the opportunity to
live a fully human life and that means
solving all those problems and you know
if you if you look at this racial strife
that's continuous in American history
well I think it breaks down into three
periods slavery which we study
extensively at Hillsdale College
discrimination and in the modern age
there's a huge apparatus of law and
subsidy to try to even out relation race
relations well that it's possible that's
not the right approach and maybe what
people need is family education and work
and our particular thing is education
right right the inner-city schools are
not good often right and why is that
well the very great Tom Sol is
publishing a book this week charter
schools and their enemies and he makes a
point
he says there's these Harlem Success
Academy so everybody should watch the
film the lottery it's a really great
it's about the lottery by which they
pick the students in any charter school
in America we have 22 charter schools
they serve thousands of people of every
color and they some of them are located
in very poor neighborhoods the
assumption is they can all learn the
same thing and they do right well this
Harlem Success Academy the the wait list
is two-thirds the size of the student
body right and that means on the day
they have the lottery a bunch of people
are heartbroken and they queue up around
the campus a circle on the streets and
shows it right and now Tom Sol makes the
point that's a performance of these
schools the kids who get into these
schools that they do better than the
average kid in the New York Public
Schools of any wealth level and yet the
public schools half a mile away they do
terrible so why why shouldn't one be
liberated right and you know we
understand around here because we've got
the difficult job of trying to teach
young lunkheads being lunkheads
ourselves that most of the learning
isn't them right and so what the
education thing that I think is fixable
and it is proved to be fixable but you
know there are enormous political
interest gathered around the monopoly on
education in the public schools and I
think especially in the inner cities
why did Hillsdale get into the business
of aiding and helping the creation of
charter schools well the short answer
there two answers and the shortest
answer is you know we really like to
teach around so let's go teach some more
so that's the same answer too though the
online course that's right online course
right and then the second thing was you
know higher education is higher and it's
very demanding and you need preparation
for that and a lot of these kids in
these poorer areas and disadvantaged
areas they don't get that preparation so
the point is if you have the means you
should try to help the ones who are in
trouble and that's hard to do it's very
hard to do and the charter school seems
to me the way to go and and we've never
been in the means of public education we
don't take money from the government for
for reasons that are profound but they
do not amount to a rejection of public
education we celebrate the Northwest
Ordinance around here passed in the same
year as the Constitution United States
that founded the public schools right so
if those schools could get better and we
think I think that the key to them
getting better is to liberate them from
the centralized control that tends to
dehumanize people and that's I think is
what happens in those in the bad schools
in the inner-city and there are very
good schools and the inner cities that
don't do that it seems like that
for decades now the the country has with
all kinds of good intentions done
initiative after initiative effort after
effort to help disadvantaged people of
all colors but to help disadvantaged
people and there just doesn't seem to be
much traction in that help as you say
the the the schools founded to help
people of whatever economic status often
don't seem to improve them very much
despite the efforts the good efforts and
the good intentions of so many people
involved maybe this is a crystal ball
question so it's unfair our charter
schools going to be given the latitude
do you think necessary to actually help
and ameliorate these problems or are
they just going to be driven off the
well I I pray so and you know the reason
I pray so is that if you think that two
things if you think public education is
a high function of government and if you
think like most things in the government
today it's become centralized and
subjective to bureaucratic rule then
charter schools is a is a lovely answer
to that and what will happen is the
charter schools will be of varying
qualities as the public schools are
today but they will vary around the
wishes of those most closely involved
I'd like to say that the proper
sovereign unit in a school in the state
in public education is the school
because in the school are gathered the
parents and the teachers and the
students and they know each other right
and it's a rare parent who doesn't care
for her child and his child right and so
they're there and they're concerned and
if they don't like this one they can go
to another one and what I think is in
this crisis that's emerged here we
should we should we should question are
we doing enough also we should question
more seriously are we doing the right
thing exactly
right if it's true that the cultivation
of the soul and body but especially the
soul is what happens in liberal
education well for the soul to be
capable of that for the soul to see
across the ages to understand to
anything outside it even the objects on
the table the classics argued that the
soul must be immaterial and a material
thing cannot have a color right and that
means that not anything to do with it
right right
you know the classic explanation of what
wisdom means in air style there's a two
main intellectual virtues but there's a
whole bunch of sub virtues in the second
category the second category is
knowledge of things that are that never
change practical judgment is making
decisions about stuff swirling all
around you well wisdom is the
accumulation of knowledge from reasoning
about things that are eternal now can
you see that takes time that's why we
think old people are wise right I am
myself am owning a reputation for wisdom
without the wisdom but but that means
that how you spend your time is crucial
and over years that accumulates to a lot
or a little and so one of the functions
of a college of a good college is to
encourage the young to spend the rest of
their lives well and you know I think we
have a fair success rate about that here
right there's an old expression for that
kind of learning you don't bump into it
too much anymore but it's it's
furnishing the mind
mm-hmm and I think I think modern ears
might misunderstand that modern ears
might think of that almost like
decoration but but that old trashin
phrase really means making the mind
habitable making it the proper place for
a proper life so so the mind really is
susceptible to a kind of furnishing and
completion
and habit acquirement that allows it to
become fully what it really is meant to
be and all that abstraction really comes
down to the necessity for a fully
developed understanding the essence of
it is we're here to do something there
will be enormous obstacles we are to
pursue the conquest and overcoming those
obstacles together and so the success in
a college means finding people who want
to do that and the more you can afford
to see we 8% of the college's revenues
come from tuition mm-hmm right just
eight eight percent right and that means
that we don't look on these kids as
profit City of sinners we'd be fools if
we did right but we look on them is
participating in the heart of the
activity that gives rise to all the
knowledge and the radiation of that
knowledge across the land and so we need
to have the right ones and we look
everywhere we can for them and more and
more you know you get better and you
grow and you get stronger and so we're
looking effectively among the
disadvantaged and we'll do that more
there's a there's a an argument you
often bump into today that the purpose
of a college education is to activate
people's ability or maybe I should just
say participation in the world of social
and political activism that that is in
other words it's training ground for
activists that that is a an argument
that is seriously proposed and seriously
taken up in colleges and universities
across the country any quick thoughts
about that well too one is what I made
activist this has been going on for 40
years always telling me why don't you be
less active think more you might be more
effective hmm in my life a turning point
in it that led me here is I read Plato's
Republic I tried to get out of it oh my
god I didn't
threes now I'm not a lawyer today the
second stage in my education was to
begin to learn about Lincoln and George
Washington the greatest Americans I
think and I came to see the beauty of
that I came to see the promise of that
now the promises of course not fully
kept this is a human thing but the
declaration dependants beckons us to
keep trying and that's you know like
what has to happen in these charter
schools and in the poor places where the
disadvantaged kids are those kids have
to be taught through the experience of
learning beautiful and high and
permanent things beginning with just a
simple relationships of moment numbers
and words but they can do anything
anything if they got the discipline you
see and then that's a calling to them
Lincoln writes it is the hope inspired
by the Declaration of Independence that
gives energy to our country we should we
should remember that document we should
remember that its purpose is to
guarantee each of us to live a human
life
that means not to be governed except by
our consent and and it means that the
government works for us and not us for
it and it means finally that you have a
right to pursue happiness which is a
tall order but what makes life
worthwhile
thank you dr. Arnn thank you for joining
us I hope this conversation has been
helpful and illuminating and it
certainly was in many respects a
microcosm of the life that occurs at
Hillsdale all the time for students only
for four years for some of us a little
bit longer than four years but some of
us are a little slower than the answer
that's it thank you very much bye-bye